tonight on the new reality they turned
off like a light switch
and there was nothing it's a mystery
scientists are working hard to solve
i didn't know who i was where i was i
don't remember doing things
no one knows how many people have
coveted 19 induced
brain injuries the virus might impact
their activities of daily living so this
is a health care issue and a societal
issue
on the night of april 18th port-a-pick
was changed
forever i can't sleep here can't shut my
eyes nearly eight months later
families and entire communities are
struggling to move forward
it was easier when there was so much
adrenaline
and now it's sinking in we can't go back
that doesn't exist anymore so we will
shape a new identity
hello i'm donna friesen we have a more
refined
understanding of the coronavirus now
than at the start of the pandemic
it has infiltrated all our lives and a
dangerous fiction has spread that it's
really only a risk to the elderly and
those with severe chronic
illness and that it's a respiratory
disease
that is simply not true there is no
iron-clad protection for anyone
and every major organ can be invaded and
infected
that includes our most complex and vital
organ
the brain and scientists believe if we
don't figure out why
it could create a ripple effect of
symptoms that last a lifetime
i couldn't think suddenly i couldn't
hold on to
any thoughts and i didn't know who i was
where i was i don't know how long i was
like that i just remember
coming out of it and still feeling
really really confused
they were not the symptoms erica taylor
was expecting
when she got covid19 she was a 31 year
old
fit active young lawyer it started with
a dry cough
and nausea and then it moved to her
brain
taylor's story starts in mid-june in
atlanta georgia
i honestly didn't think that i had covet
but
i got tested as a precaution because i
knew that i was planning to go to
the courthouse the next week two days
later the results came back
positive i remember being
completely floored i think the first
thing that i said was
actually an expletive i tried to work
and i got so tired and so confused
trying to stare at my computer screen
i fully expected that within a day or so
i would start to feel better
but that didn't happen over a period of
six weeks there were
headaches then memory loss and serious
bouts of confusion
i forget things that i just did
i don't remember doing things i forget
words
i don't remember grammar all the time
it's called brain fog a gentle term to
describe a series of symptoms that can
include dizziness
trouble focusing and grasping everyday
words
when the coronavirus infects the brain
it can cause inflammation
it can cause strokes and autopsies have
found virus
particles in the brains of some people
who died from covet 19.
in november researchers found nearly 10
to 35 percent of covid19 survivors in
the u.s
experienced disabling and persistent
neurological symptoms
it's a mystery scientists including here
in canada
are working hard to solve simon graham
at the sunnybrook research institute in
toronto
is leading a team studying how covid
impacts the brain
what is your concern in the years ahead
for people who
perhaps have recovered from the worst of
the symptoms the virus might impact the
brain
in certain people impairing their
activities of daily living
potentially stopping them from being
gainfully employed
and so this is a healthcare issue and a
societal issue
they're recruiting former covid19
patients some with lingering symptoms
and doing mris but how does the virus
get into the brain
in the first place one theory is tied to
that telltale symptom
loss of sense of smell the virus can get
into the body through the nasal cavity
and from there it might be able to
migrate up
into different parts of the brain
including the orbital frontal cortex
interestingly the brain is covered with
a membrane called the dura
and the orbital frontal cortex actually
doesn't have any dura it's the only part
of the brain
that has this potential pathway and so
the virus can get in there and then in
animals at least
it's migrated down into areas kind of
lower in the brain
that are responsible for controlling
respiration
and the heartbeat so that is more of a
sort of
top down right the brain getting hit
first
and then it moving down through other
organs that's right
and so there are examples of people who
have only had neurological
symptoms and not respiratory symptoms
hi my name is tracy thompson and i live
in toronto ontario canada and i'm
making this video to put out in the
world in case i don't make it through
this
if i do tracy thompson fears covid will
kill her the 52 year old says her first
symptoms were sore throat
fatigue and then sudden loss of smell
and taste
i'm eating food and from one bite to the
next
that said that's the sense is just
turned off right they turned off like a
light switch
and there was nothing like a complete
absence no salt no sweet no nothing
just texture more than eight months
later thompson is still
barely getting by her short-term memory
is non-existent like running a bath is a
treacherous thing to do now because
i have to sit there and watch it because
i don't know if i leave the room if i'm
going to remember that that's what i was
doing
now she has to set multiple alarms as
reminders
to carry out everyday tasks i was
extremely healthy
before this you know i worked in a
kitchen i was a chef i work the line i
can
rock and roll with the best of them you
know if this is a permanent state for me
i'm going to have to figure out a new
way
to be in the world my wall of post-it
notes can't travel with me
so no one knows how many people have
covid 19-induced
brain injuries in canada there aren't
many requirements to track these type of
symptoms
teresa lou ambrose is the director of
the aging mobility and cognitive
neuroscience laboratory
at the university of british columbia a
lot of the
damages that we see within the brain
takes years to accrue with covet 19 the
emerging evidence is that it's quite
rapid in terms of its effects
a recent study published in neurology
showed out of 160 stroke patients with
covid19
50 of cases involving younger patients
didn't have a call for trouble breathing
as the first symptoms
they had a stroke
lou ambrose's team is part of the
canadian longitudinal study
on aging covid19 brain health which
plans to track participants until
twenty thirty three using neuroimaging
they hope to study the brains of about
one thousand people
some with the virus and some without so
the impact of covet 19 on the brain
could be thought of as
accelerating brain aging so when we age
one of the common things that happens
within our brain is that the blood
vessels
do become compromised evidence suggests
covid19
impacts the same blood vessels that feed
the brain
if the virus is damaging those vessels
which speeds up aging
it means some survivors might be at risk
of developing early onset dementia
with covet 19 what we're seeing is that
it seems quite rapid that you would
actually see these
neuroimaging markers and those who were
acutely infected
and i i can't think of another condition
where we've seen that
previously my legs got it really hurt
and um
i feel dizzy as for erica taylor
she hasn't gone back to work yet she's
on medical leave
and spends her days going from
appointment to appointment
trying to get to the bottom of her brain
fog
i've gotten a little bit better as i've
gone
with my neurological symptoms with being
able to think and remember
but i'm still struggling a lot and you
know i
to be a lawyer means to use your brain
and
i don't know i don't know if i'll ever
get to the point where i'll be be the
same i do i fear that a lot
coming up on the new reality it was one
of the worst mass killing sprees in
canadian history
i lost my friends i woke up to a horror
show i'll never get over it nearly eight
months later
communities are struggling to move
forward we can't go back
to before april 18th that doesn't exist
anymore
we're trying to figure out what who are
we now
welcome back for 13 hours a shooting
rampage terrified a community in nova
scotia
when it was over 22 people were dead
that was almost
eight months ago the people of
port-au-prince are still traumatized
some are contemplating moving to get
away from the horrific memories
that haunt them ross lord return to the
once peaceful community
to see if healing is even possible
the tiny community of port-a-pick is a
natural haven
located on the beautiful nova scotia
coastline it's a place to relax
and get away from it all a place where
people know their neighbors
it's now also a place some people want
to leave
to escape the trauma inflicted on them
by one of those very
same neighbors i lost my friends i woke
up to a horror show
i'll never get over it
so there's a structure fire there's a
person down there with a gun they're
still looking for them
on the night of april 18th port-a-pick
was changed
forever for 13 hours a gunman named
gabriel wartman
went on a rampage leaving a trail of
burnt wreckage and bodies in porter pick
and beyond
[Music]
when it was over he had murdered 22
people
it was one of the worst mass killing
sprees in canadian history
and it all started here i fell asleep
just before i
was dozing off her like a pop pop sound
like a shotgun or gunshot i didn't know
what it
sounded like so i just fell asleep leon
jordry woke up at 4am
to scenes of unimaginable horror
he like many is having trouble coping
with the memories of that night
never will make sense to me it's just
unbelievable what happened
but it happened police say it began with
an argument that turned violent between
wartman
and his common law partner lisa banfield
then
wartman set two of his own properties on
fire and went on the hunt
greg and jamie blair were among
wortman's first victims
son tyler thinks he knows why his father
was targeted
i can only think because he knew there
was a big hunter he had lots of rifles
and
that could have threw a stick into his
whole plan
it's believed wartman killed the blairs
around 10 pm
while their two younger sons hid in the
house when they realized wortman was
trying to set the house on fire
the boys escaped running to the nearby
house of lisa mccully
mccully was a beloved elementary school
teacher
and a single parent of two
she was just so dynamic and involved
and passionate and protective
and constantly coming up with new and
creative ideas
macaulay noticed massive flames coming
from ortman's place across the road
she called 9-1-1 she saw what looked
like a police car and a man dressed like
an rcmp
officer it was wartman he shot and
killed her
after wartman left the blair boys
arrived from next door
together with mccauley's two kids they
hid in the basement
the children talked with the 9-1-1
dispatcher for two
hours waiting for help to arrive
[Music]
earlier on that saturday evening lisa
walked along the beach
with a glass of wine she sent her sister
jenny a picture
after lisa's death jenny posted a
matching image in tribute
but at times the pain of loss is almost
unbearable
there are moments when it's just really
intense
the blair and mccully kids survived but
13
other people in port-au-prince died that
night it's possible
none of them could have been saved but
the rampage
didn't end there among the many
unanswered questions is how the gunman
escaped from port-au-pick to continue
the massacre
despite police claims there were more
than two dozen officers on the scene
very quickly
it's very vague what's going on down
on the night of april 18th rcmp arrived
in port-au-prince shortly before 10 30
p.m
global news has learned wartman was in
the area until at least 10
45 nearly 20 minutes later
so how was he able to escape and kill
nine more people
over the next 12 hours the mounties had
blocked off the main road in and out of
portopic
but they left this dirt road unattended
they say it's likely wartman used that
road to get past police
and connect with the highway which
they'd left open that's
how we get out and there's only one way
out here other than the way
of the entrance so that's why it's
important
in addition to his knowledge of the back
roads wartman
had another big advantage he spent a lot
of time and money collecting
rcmp memorabilia he had uniforms and
several former police cruisers
and one had all the markings of the real
thing
once he escaped porter pick he used his
disguise to continue the killing spree
he didn't hide that fact that he had
cars or memorabilia from people
that knew him in fact wartman had a
fully marked replica cruiser on display
at his warehouse in puerto pick
shown in this photo obtained by global
news it was taken in november
five months before the rampage as
wartman's killing spree was unfolding
a witness in portopic told police the
gunman was driving
what looked like an rcmp car they
believed he had three such cars and
quickly accounted for them
what they didn't know is there was a
fourth vehicle
the same one that had been sitting in
his warehouse for months
they assumed he committed suicide and
was in the community
by assuming that allowed him to kill
people outside portopic
no it was just inexcusable for hours the
public got
no information other than one vague
tweet about a firearms complaint around
11
30 pm people had no warning that wartman
was driving a replica cruiser and
wearing an rcmp uniform
until after 10 am the following morning
more than 10 hours later years earlier
there were multiple complaints about
wartman
that he talked about killing cops that
he physically abused his girlfriend
that he had illegal weapons the
complaints
went nowhere the rcmp's failures before
during and after the massacre have
shaken people's trust
criminologist daryl davies says rcmp
clearly have not learned from
previous deadly shooting rampages like
moncton new brunswick in 2014.
port-a-pick is more of a i would say a
gross exaggeration
of you know of the organization's
inability to be able to handle that type
of situation
witnesses have told police wartman had
become increasingly agitated about the
pandemic
davies says rcmp should have been better
prepared
in light of the lockdown and the
pandemic and everything the possibility
that some
it would trigger something like this in
somebody who was you know mentally
unstable
was a very high probability they got the
killer right here
when the onslaught finally ended it was
by chance an rcmp officer who stopped
for fuel at this gas station
encountered wartman who had stolen a car
from one of his victims
and needed gas
the officer shot and killed the gunman
at 11 26 a.m on april 19th
13 hours after the massacre started
in all he killed 22 people at 16 crime
scenes
including rcmp veteran constable heidi
stevenson
a mother of two children
nearly eight months later families and
entire communities are struggling to
move forward
we're trying to figure out what who who
are we now
serena lewis is nova scotia's grief
coordinator
she lives near puerto pick her own
family was locked down during the
massacre
we can't go back to before april 18th
that that doesn't exist anymore
so we will shape a new identity some
people globally have told me this could
be a 20-year span for these communities
that's if we lean in lewis says grief
counseling is already under resourced in
nova scotia
and healing is even harder during the
pandemic when physical contact is
discouraged
now common things can be emotional
triggers
even the mere sight of an rcmp vehicle
you know if you see a car coming with
the lights on behind you
what does that do for people i was in a
a gathering uh the other day and i had
to stop everybody because i could feel
it and i said you know kind of how's
everybody doing
here tonight given the fact that we've
had the largest mass shooting
in canada and a woman looked at me and
she said are we really allowed to talk
about that elephant
for families pursuing answers has led to
more pain
on december 4 the rcmp did announce it
was charging wartman's common law
partner lisa banfield and two others
with illegally transferring ammunition
to the gunman
rcmp claimed the three had no prior
knowledge of ortman's actions on april
18th and 19th
but many other questions remain
grief-stricken families had to protest
before the federal and nova scotia
governments
agreed to a full public inquiry they'll
have to wait
two years for the inquiry's final report
the massacre has drawn condolences from
across the country
but the outpouring only goes so far
victim's relatives like jenny kirsten
are struggling to cope with their grief
it was easier when there was so much
adrenaline
and now it's sinking in
before his dad was killed tyler blair
and his partner had a baby daughter
he remembers how happy his dad was when
he found out he'd be a grandfather
i told my dad on her way to work one
morning his face just lit up
he was no he was super excited
he was more excited than i was i think
she will only know her grandparents from
pictures i'll make sure
she knows how much they loved her
some residents are literally moving on
port-a-pick is dotted with for sale
signs
leon jodry has not slept in his house
since that horrific night
he's decided to leave hoping that will
finally
bring him peace i can't sleep here can't
shut my eyes so
it's my choice not to stay here i'm
selling mine i can't speak for anybody
else i'm selling mine for the images i
got in my head of driving around that
night i drive here it's all i see
next week on the new reality things have
really accelerated with wave 2
and it's disheartening there's certainly
there's no other way to put it
our staff are fatigued so half the icu
right now is
they're all on life support in one way
or the other we're seeing outbreaks and
families and we're seeing that when
family members are visiting other family
members and putting those people at risk
how worried are you about going into
christmas and what might be waiting for
us on the other side of that
very like unequivocally very
that is the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen
thanks for watching
you